[Music]
and I didn't know news yeah you did
ended by I've got sunshine while I was
[ __ ] up I'm not pilot was arrested for
standing naked at his hotel window what
Oh feel like you should be allowed to do
that I've done that we have this
conversation you can't do that butoh
windows were like you couldn't see in
like in Vegas you can't see in there
told you said just see could put you
against it no he would never you won't
have sex in public or next to a window
Nicky it's me it is it's gross
what's messy having sex in public places
what if it's a big doghouse
I'm sorry a doghouse like a big doghouse
where it's not messy anymore
it is Messier there's dog [ __ ] in there
don't involve no like if you got a pet
Kahn there's a really big dog huh
brand-new brand-new yeah oh yeah it's
not what I want I want a spontaneous
spur of the moment we're drinking it's
like hey I want to get away to that
bathroom and like because we're really
horny right now in this moment that's
what I'm talking about it takes you away
why bars next to the Petco this sounds
like a very specific thing sex and Home
Depot or something right like in one of
those gardening sheds or something you
know me you told me not in a gardening
shed okay let's go into semantics now
what was it an enormous barn
oh my god okay anyway what happened so
this pilot who has worked for United
Airlines for 22 years was standing naked
at the window of his 10th floor hotel
room after he just like he was about to
go take a shower and he was like on a
phone like oh are you sure that's what
he's doing I blew some weird [ __ ] yeah
me too I do it all the time
right across from his window of the
airport the Denver Airport I think
you're gonna say like a elementary
school you know I wake you up and burn
or like a nunnery nunneries his job was
across the street but I still feel like
those windows are supposed to be
reflective only taught to sew because he
was looking into the airport and he
couldn't you can't see anyone there so
you like always really gotta be looking
like everything's a long and wide and
far so was it air traffic controller
more like this as long a minor fire too
so yeah for passengers waiting for their
flights looked up and saw him fully nude
so then that's on the cob all right I
get it cuz he's not hot cuz if he was
hot no one would give a [ __ ] true if I
give these khal drogo just my god yeah
who'd give a [ __ ] so all the girls would
be like sometimes they do give a [ __ ]
because the husbands are like why are
you distracted by that look gross he's
not I'm gonna call the cops while
they're still looking yeah so I'm gonna
show you a photo of this poor pilot
what city was Oh cuz there be ugly
people endeavour looks like the white
version of my dad he does he could have
been a dad really looks like that oh
that's weird say no cousin you're him
speak you look so sad if you have a
really deep voice it is the white
version of your dad all right
I'm gonna show you guys a video clip of
when you got arrested he's doing
something weird like you banging off at
the window I bet you he doesn't he
refused but there wouldn't the people
calling say like yeah yeah what is the
call hey you guys this is that you know
what I don't understand is why would why
would you get like handcuffed and taken
to jail for that because people get
caught for pissing on the street and
then they get indecent
exposure or whatever money is just a
ticket or something I don't know and you
got to go to court later that's crazy
that's why they're like now he's his
lawyer is going to file a lawsuit on
your behalf
oh he's gonna get money because of this
so what special that video got released
that's [ __ ] how they got body cams
now so cops can't keep lying that's true
and how close are these passengers cuz
how do they know he's not just wearing a
beige suit they're saying he's a
ballerina
yeah people have patience banks he would
if he got some Spanx I should be body
shaming here supporting the man for
getting out of this outfit true cuz the
only place I've seen Spanx is always at
the airport so he probably was watching
by one day like I need a pair of those
yeah aren't they like now not letting
some women fly on United Airlines
because they're wearing too tight a
leggings they're like calling it that
it's indecent
well the lemon is fully going out of
business no good it'll be fine because
girls are wearing really tight leggings
and this is some oppressive bullsh
airlines are saying women can't get on
the flight because it's too tight and it
looks like they're just wearing slinky
[ __ ] GOG look leggings were like
they were like you know a very smooth
naked dolphin thanks for remembering
girl I know I wrote because I wanted to
buy a pair but because you were starting
at my in London yeah well that too
because I was like my ask who look like
that if I bought look like that better
oh thank you that's how I get her
compliment from Geo was just trying to
take it away
I like Joe's balls thank you what I just
want I want to support the positivity he
didn't give you a he didn't give you a
compliment back you see that's why I
haven't really seen his balls cuz he has
a lot of pubic hair no he doesn't well
when I remember okay he had a lot of
people I shaved it I'm sorry I never saw
his balls I did see his big no matter
what I like a little bit he's like said
she's like stubble a little bit yeah
I like it rough I like stubble on
footballs I love it
likes five o'clock shadow like this yeah
not smooth balls stumbled upon something
that's like a torture device that's so
specific but that's like a man you know
to me like a ball and chain like yo you
like when he goes down on you if he has
like a little school uh
he barely grows anything so I can't feel
it he doesn't do that shape to get me
the man yeah you don't get ingrown hairs
I don't like shaving because it gives me
ingrown hairs maybe because my hair is
really thick mmm bragging Steve missing
girl right you should try getting
lasered vile girl like thinner you could
still get ingrown hairs though in you
loser I got a scar on my [ __ ] from
getting lasered one yeah you got me too
hard and now it looks questionable so I
need me no just questionable you know
what I mean like when someone's go down
here and they're like what's that and
you're like I started [ __ ] god it's a
scar from laser hair removal it's a scar
from the other mother [ __ ] that asked
me what it was and I beat his [ __ ]
ass I just keep [ __ ] working
Thank You where are you and I need you
I'll be there in your vagina ain't the
guy he's probably like what is that okay
to put the napkin on and he goes down
[Laughter]
where the bin yeah with a plate so the
us how far away they were the lawyer the
dude's lawyer is saying that it was
about a hundred yards away or more it's
a football field they had the binoculars
they weren't looking for trouble this is
some
I think they wanted to get this guy
fired and they were looking for a reason
to get him fired and that's the reason
they could have he's just a bad pilot
and they were like you can't fault him
for that because the plane is basically
flying like tenured or whatever he's mr.
turbulence yeah every time he flies that
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] like this they got too
tired of that [ __ ] and he always goes no
he spent two days in jail yeah that's
pretty intense did some [ __ ] a
misdemeanor charge of indecent exposure
and so he was suspended from flying on
United for six months that's longer than
like when someone drinks and damn I've
done this so many times I really don't
think that it was because of the
indecent exposure that this guy
thoroughly surprised though he was like
really yeah I didn't he was in his
underwear so that means he just put on
boxers on and he opened the door no he
was indeed yeah you just topless oh yeah
okay I thought it was like green
underwear unfortune yeah no it might
even s be exposed this way no I know and
if he's like not guilty then everyone's
gonna remember him nude days would you
do two days in jail plus six months of
being shamed for probably millions of
dollars that he's gonna get I'll do a
month in jail call me the naked whatever
I'm balling and all I have to do is show
my dick easy I just want to go to jail
for two days what I never been yo yeah
different hats so this one's a what's
that what hat is this one's a bucket
list hat a bucket list huh actually
always one of those things
well what kind of gel are we talking
about besides a me
there's there's maximum security you're
probably gonna get raped jail is that
the one you want just a couple of days
why is that the one you want though
County Jail is a little bit different
County Jail is like you got your gangs
but you also got your DUI people and
average citizen you know what I heard as
nice as death row jail you get to like
play tennis and things like that because
you can do that here but they know
you're gonna die just be a citizen
Avella
but then you get to play tennis with
shoes like ten sizes too big you get to
wear like a towel it's like to be told
what to do the whole day you just need
to get into domination break you the job
no but yeah like okay you need to wake
up at this time this is the time that
you eat this is the time you go to a
summer camp there's a timing a boot camp
yeah try that the time you need their
summer boot camp I just wanna know what
jails like okay I don't know it so you
and Bart are on the same page right now
go for it you're joining Bart on this
page I understand what I'm doing you
aren't crazy now she's doing you're
crazy you are crazy stone because my
friend is like a twist he's like this
actually one of the things I like from
when I was a kid like I've always wanted
to go to jail are you surprised you know
TIFF is the experienced person I am I
want to try everything once I've been
going to jail is one of those things you
would not last a day I know I don't know
you but like no I feel like I'm you
might Apple watch on except for you
don't wanna go to jail no I doubt we
would not drive we do not do you watch
locked up where those shows I have
before Gordon you watch orange is the
new black where I'm like maybe that's
not so bad black makes it seem high like
I'm gonna find my girlfriend then it
makes it seem like wow you get forced
friends oh god why does everything go
back in French
are we not enough for you no you guys
are great
my friends like a real Yelp reviewer for
jails cuz he's been into couple of jails
and he says that at least like probably
the hardest were the other ones it's
just people go there to kind of spend
time and then they're just doing their
thing even though there is gang activity
and and stuff it's not as hard as LA
County isn't there a lot of corruption
too like I've seen videos where the
police are just straight-up like beating
up some prisoners from yeah oh yeah I
know I know some colored guys I met a
guy that was getting tattoo work done on
by my buddy
and it was it was at a backyard party
and we're hanging out with them and
ironically he's he was becoming an
officer so he was a former gang member
that was getting tattoo work two covers
gang tattoos joined the military
becoming an officer and in order to do
that he also was a jailer so he was
working in Corrections and then he says
she told me this one story work he
walked by and this guy spit at him so he
looked around and then they opened the
jail cell and beat the living [ __ ] out
of the dude and he walked out pop
larious I'm like awesome that's our
world
that's our [ __ ] world so have fun
guys I'm system is broken as [ __ ]
[Music]